let's go to Devin from Virginia Devin
from Virginia welcome to the David
packman show
oh thank you
um yeah I want to talk about my state
and kind of like how it's not really
doing great uh specifically about them
unfortunatic so my ID to access an adult
website called uh PornHub and
um now there are loopholes to this like
I could simply turn off my Wi-Fi and I
can access it so it's a very flawed
system well wait if you turn off Wi-Fi
how do you access a website do you don't
you need the internet connection
uh with my data on my phone
I see what you're saying yeah so yeah so
it's the big loopholes and like VPN so
it's not really effective and it's like
very dangerous right if you show your
ideal porno like it can easily be your
ID can be stolen so yeah it's just I
don't really so have you and your
friends sort of like uh figured out how
to get around this ID requirement
uh yeah yeah like I said VPN is done
like search like uh thing on Google when
it happened
um and others as well too so yeah it's
like it's not very effective it's more
dangerous for people and for children
it's just like I I don't know if you say
culture War protected kids type stuff I
don't know no thinking bigger picture
other than difficulty access slight
difficulty accessing porn what else
don't you like that's going on in
Virginia
um let's see I would say our governor
like he uh he won based on us you know
saying uh critical race series in our
schools yeah and that boosted him and he
won based off that and I was really
disappointed with Virginians uh for sure
because I thought would be smarter than
that I guess not
um yeah yeah I know it's just
it's you know it's it's tough you know
are you thinking about moving
um yeah when I'm able to have the funds
for it yeah for sure I would definitely
like to move maybe in Colorado right
I've always liked the cold so yeah well
Devin we're sending you our best all
right
thanks I appreciate a lot all right
Devin from Virginia sticking it out he's
figured out how to get the porn but
still struggling with the governor
that's uh
that's a situation that's for sure